meghan markle's still healing from her
traumatic experience with the royal
family it's a confession she makes in
the cuts fall fashion issue getting real
about her journey from hollywood actress
to the duchess of sussex
my entire job was tell me where to stand
tell me what to say tell me how to say
it tell me what to wear and i'll do it i
will say i went into it naively
because i didn't grow up
knowing much about the royal family it
wasn't something that was part of
conversation at home i did anything they
told me to do of course i did because it
was also through the lens of and we'll
protect you was only once we were
married and everything started to really
worsen
that i came to understand that not only
was i not being protected they weren't
willing to tell the truth to protect me
and my husband
it's been over a year since that
tell-all chat with oprah and this new
interview with the cut echoes a lot of
what megan said back then i don't know
how they could expect that after all of
this time
[Music]
we would still just be silent if there
is an active role
that the firm is playing
in perpetuating
falsehoods about us
that at a certain point you're gonna go
but you guys someone just tell the truth
the biggest update megan offers where
she and harry stand with his family
today the sussexes have made it clear
they have no desire to go back to the
royal family they have carved a new life
for themselves in california
megan tells the cut she's open to
mending fences with her in-laws and with
her own estranged family her father
included quote i think forgiveness is
really important it takes a lot more
energy to not forgive but it takes a lot
of effort to forgive i've really made an
active effort especially knowing that i
can say anything there's a lot to work
through there
megan admits she's cautious about what
she shares publicly but we'll be hearing
a lot more from her soon she plans to
post more on instagram plus she and
harry have a netflix series in the works
and her podcast just hit the top of the
spotify charts people should expect the
real me in this and probably the me that
they've never gotten to know certainly
not in the past few years
where everything is through the lens of
the media
quote
i have a lot to say until i don't do you
like that sometimes as they say the
silent part is still part of the song i
think it's the case that megan
certainly feels that she was um
silenced to a degree she has spoken
about um being able to use her voice now
which i think suggests that as a member
as a working member of the royal family
and she felt at times restricted how
really when she married into the royal
family she essentially lost her voice
she lost her platform with the podcast
the duchess promises to break down the
labels that try to hold women back hey
come to me i'm just excited to be myself
and talk and be unfiltered and
yeah it's fun
[Music]
you